and now a shout-out to recognize some of
the excellent investigative reporting
being done around the country that often
doesn't get as much recognition as it
deserves today a shout-out to the Miami
Herald for its explosive investigation
into how this billionaire convicted sex
offender Jeffrey Epstein
was able to get what was essentially a
slap on the wrist for abusing dozens of
underage girls we didn't really know how
many there were
but I mean part of the story is how much
was kept secret in in the court
documents reporter Julie Brown spent
more than a year tracking down the young
women who were Epstein's victims I
probably spoke with about eight and of
those eight only four wanted to go on
the you know courageous enough to go on
the record in a powerful video Brown
produced with her partner
Emily Michelle we were underage we were
little girls I was 16 I was 16 I started
going to him when I was like 14 15 14
turning 15 if you think at 14 $200
that's a lot of money at 14 years olds I
mean that's a lot of money now and then
Brown spent countless hours doing
journalism the old fashioned
tried-and-true way to learn about the
lenient deal federal prosecutors cut
with Epstein requiring him to serve only
13 months in the county jail these are
10 to 12 years worth of documents there
was probably thousands if not tens of
thousands of documents to wade through
but the turning point came Brown says
when two key police officials trusted
her enough to lay out what really
happened behind the scenes it started
out and given me in a back road but many
cases it turned into something far worse
than that elevated to a crime and a
serious crime that what he had the
plaintiff was a joke the sentence he
served it was even a bigger joke and
then his probation was a slap in
everybody's face I think once the police
chief was willing to go on the record
with me and the
lead detective both of them had never
given interviews before and I think
after we did their interviews we really
realize how how good of a story we had
and it went to the heart of how much
influence Epstein had and how he and his
the people that work for him
bullied everyone associated with this
case and look who knows what else is
going to come out I mean that the
excellent journalism is now has spread
the message it's not just a state court
case that stuck in Palm Beach County now
people are really aware of what's going
on Browns reporting raised questions
about the federal prosecutor at the time
Alex Acosta who is now the Secretary of
Labor in the Trump administration he
seemed to go to great lengths to cut a
lenient deal with Epstein and keep the
whole process secret
according to Brown Acosta defended the
deal during his Senate confirmation
hearings this debt mr. Epstein should
plead guilty to two years register as a
sex offender and concede liability so
the victims could get restitution and if
that were done the federal interest
would be satisfied and we would refer to
the state Brown got no comment from
Epstein nor did we but one of his
lawyers Alan Dershowitz told me he was
proud of the deal he made for his client
so no regrets then and arranging a deal
in which he spent only 13 months behind
only ten months I mean the job of
criminal defense lawyers to get the best
possible deal if I had been able to get
him in the over he spent no time in
prison that would have been even better
members of Congress have now asked for a
full investigation of the deal in the
wake of Julie Browns reporting and she
is continuing on the story knowing that
her efforts made a difference and gave
Epstein John victims a sense of justice
that the Department of Justice did not
they were made to believe that they were
prostitutes so they finally said
someone's finally understanding that we
weren't prostitutes we were girls he
violated us
maybe now something will change I think
they're still hoping for a sense of
justice that something will be done in
the case and so our shout out this week
to Julie brown
Emily me show and the Miami Herald
that's our program for this week thanks
for joining us we'll be back again next
week